nfts look
most people still have no clue what a
bitcoin is what blockchain is most
people still have no idea so
why don't you explain it in your words
when you think about blockchain
then go to cryptocurrency hypothetically
bitcoin ethereum whatever it is explain
that
then go to nft so give me a series of
educating each
then leading into nfts sure so the
blockchain is basically just a series of
sort of like
looking at like a big spreadsheet where
everybody can like
add rows to it and everybody agrees on
this spreadsheet so everybody kind of
agrees okay this is what's happened
these are all the transactions and this
is what's happened so
what that allows you to do is have
something like a bitcoin
and you can't just copy and paste it
because everybody else will be like
no no no you can't do that that's not
part of the rules
so with bitcoin again you can't just
okay i've got
one copy and paste now i've got two like
that's not how it works
that's why bitcoin actually has value
and nfts are very similar to that
there exist on the blockchain it's
another thing sort of written to the
blockchain in this case it's an
ethereum which is a different blockchain
than sort of
bitcoin there's there's multiple
different blockchains um
basically like multiple different sort
of spreadsheets that everybody's kind of
agreeing on
and with ethereum you can also sort of
program in rules for how these sort of
like
you know things on the blockchain work
so you can put little programs on top of
the like tokens and stuff
so the nfts is really just a proof of
ownership
it's really just proving you own this
token on the blockchain and the the
token
itself can kind of point to different
things it's kind of say okay well this
token
points to a picture this token points to
a video
this token points to a thing and and
just like uh with bitcoin
you can prove you are the only person
that owns it and you can't just
copy and paste and okay now i've got two
of them so
it is a very hard it is a very sort of
um
you know different sort of paradigm from
what we've been used to with digital
whereas with you know digital and the
internet and computers
we're used to you copy a file you copy
another here's another copy here's
another copy
we can just make a million copies all
day nobody knows where the first one was
they're all completely identical who
cares no you can't own it
you're just it's just out there and you
make another copy and
so it is a bit you know sort of hard to
to kind of wrap your head around and it
is a different like sort of like
paradigm shift but i think
once people do they'll realize that it's
sort of
um it's really similar to owning a bunch
of different things
that there's different analogies for for
owning something virtual
and sort of applying value to that that
that already exists so say
like an mp3 um
you know you can have a million copies
of sort of you know michael jackson's
thriller but that's
very different from the person who owns
the master recording
and so when you have a copy of it nobody
thinks oh
okay well you own thriller like of
course you don't
like you don't own the master recording
and so that's what it's kind of like
with this
anybody can download a copy of my
picture
but that doesn't mean you own it because
you don't own the token
that says you own the picture well then
that's a follow-up so here's a follow-up
question that comes on that so sure
if you own the master of michael jackson
or beatles or whoever they are which
elvis presley those are pretty valuable
you know masters to own
if i play that song on a video
youtube would flag it and bring it back
and say you have to pay these guys xyz
if i listen to the song i have to pay 99
cents to itunes or buck 29.
if i buy an album i have to pay 30 bucks
or whatever it may be right
if you own if you own every days yep and
somebody else decides to use it
does the how do you monetize the master
of that
nft that you own it's it is a little
different it's not exactly like that
it's more just about sort of like owning
like a painting it's it's more
in that case it's sort of like there's a
bunch of copies but it's more like
owning a painting where it's sort of
like
it's not as quite as easy to sort of
directly monetize like that because
there is no way to stop people from like
sharing this stuff
um so that's not a perfect analogy but
it's one analogy that kind of shows that
a bunch of people can own a copy
but then one person can own sort of the
like this is the person who owns it
well a bunch of copies still exist so
let's talk about the painting so if it's
a painting
and i come to your house and i say mike
wow
what is that painting you say it's a
video it's
whatever you tell me i'm like oh my gosh
when it was painted in 1973
before etc he was going through a
divorce and he died nine years later so
essentially this is his last whatever
okay
unbelievable what'd you pay for this 17
million bucks unbelievable man enjoy it
but with this one here i don't really
have a place to put it on there right
because
i can i can put every day's as a digital
on a
120 inch screen tv in my house and say
look at what mike built together this is
beautiful
but i don't own it how is the element of
art
being appreciated for the work that you
did during those 5 000 days
yep so i think it is that is true and
that's another part of ownership that
is very different here because in the
past a big piece of ownership
was restricting access so in that case
you just talked about
you had to go into that guy's house he
had to let you into his house
to see this painting that's not what
this is it's
really just about proving ownership so
it that's another thing that's a little
bit hard for people to wrap their heads
around because in the past it's sort of
like if you wanted to own something
online the way you showed that is you
put it behind
a pay wall you said no you need to give
me money first to see it
that's not what this is it's really
about kind of the opposite of that
actually the more popular this painting
this
picture gets the more valuable it will
be
sort of an example of that is you go
into the loo and you take a picture of
the mona lisa
and you share that online well you just
made another copy of the mona lisa
available do you think that makes the
mona lisa
less valuable because you did that no
of course not like it's a little like
absolutely not
it's the most it is the most valuable
painting because it's the most
famous painting that's the thing and
that's what
if we can if i can make this and
manikova can make this the most famous
painting
then it will be the most valuable
painting and so that's
that's kind of like what this is it's
sort of like it's not about
sort of restricting people's access to
it it's just about proving who owns it
so in the case that you said um you know
this thing how is
how are people gonna see it how are they
gonna experience it well we're gonna try
and get it in museums all over the world
and here's the advantage that something
digital has
is it doesn't have to take just one form
that's right like when you have a
painting
that guy your buddy's painting one
there's only one painting
it's locked away in his house nobody's
enjoying it nobody's seeing it
and with this it can take a bunch of
different
forms and it can take a bunch of
different forms over time
so i can make a a copy of it from matic
foam bag here
i'm going to make a big print for you
and your house this is just for you
here's a copy of it
and then we're going to make a
installation in this museum and we're
going to you know get a bunch of
projectors and make a big huge
massive massive projection and that's
going to be in this san francisco museum
then we're going to have this this
museum in hong kong they've got a bunch
of screens we're going to put a bunch of
screens in this thing and we're going to
make a
copy of it there so this artwork because
it's digital
could actually exist in
a bunch of different places at the same
time and be have people experiencing it
and viewing it and each one could be
slightly
different too so it's something where uh
there are some advantages like that to
to um
you know digital artwork because again
at the end of the day it has to come
into the physical world somehow
so whether that's on a computer screen
whether that's on a phone
you are viewing it in the real world
somehow so
i think that's that's a huge advantage
of it can take a bunch of different
forms
but then the nft is still sort of the
kind of piece of it that kind of
that is the actual sort of artwork does
that make sense it is again it's a it's
a bit hard
a different way of looking at it so if
you like this sort of short clip from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel
take care everybody bye